When a hyper-aggressive lizard or an evil,
living cow-heart starts rampaging through
your town, or a sinister salesman turns up
in your home, who you gonna call?
Hint, it’s not the Ghostbusters.
The answer is… the SCP Foundation’s Mobile
Task Force.
You’ve probably heard them mentioned in
every single video on this channel, but what
exactly is a Mobile Task Force?
What do they do for the SCP Foundation and
what are some of the most famous Mobile Task
Forces in the field?
Let’s crack open the files and take a look!
In short, Mobile Task Forces are the Foundation’s
elite personnel, and each task force is generally
made up of highly-trained Foundation operatives
with specific skill sets.
These MTFs aren’t rooted to any one base,
and are relocated to wherever they’re required
– hence the “Mobile” part of their name.
The exact parameters of what an MTF can be
is pretty flexible – the size of their units
can vary from whole battalions of troops packing
heavy artillery to smale, tight-knit groups
of intelligence-gathering spies.
Some Mobile Task Forces are bound to specific
SCPs, whereas others perform more generalized
tasks, such as securing certain facilities
or territories.
When the regular rank and file Foundation
Field Agents can’t do the job, the MTFs
are brought in to pick up the pieces.
Each group is controlled by a Mobile Task
Force Commander, who reports to the Foundation
Director of Task Forces, though the actual
organizational structure of each group varies.
Sometimes, MTFs which were created for extremely
specific purposes are disbanded after that
purpose is achieved.
How many Mobile Task Forces are there, exactly?
The exact number is shrouded in secrecy, and
oftentimes the answer will depend on who you
ask.
But you’re not here for what we don’t
know.
You want to know the details on the biggest
badasses under the Foundation’s employ,
and we intend to deliver.
Much like our video on the proposals for SCP
– 001, we’re going to give you a rapid
fire crash-course on some of the most prominent
and interesting Foundation task forces.
And remember, if you want us to go more in
depth into the most exciting missions of any
of these groups, let us know in the comments!
But for now, it’s time for a rundown of
the Foundation’s best of the best.
MTF Alpha-1, aka "Red Right Hand", are essentially
the Black Ops of the SCP Foundation.
They report directly to the O5 Council and
conduct missions at the highest level of secrecy
– with most of the information hidden behind
a Level 5 clearance wall.
Many also believe Alpha-1 to have a link to
the infamous Chaos Insurgency – a splinter
group at war with the Foundation – but if
anyone asks, you didn’t hear it from us.
Seriously, we don’t want to get assassinated.
MTF Alpha-4, aka "Pony Express", are a covert
group deeply embedded in the world’s logistics
and postal services.
The trafficking of anomalous objects is a
worldwide issue, and it’s up to Alpha-4
to intercept and keep a lid on these anomalous
objects before they fall into the wrong hands.
Think of them as a better-funded, paranormal
USPS Police Division.
One object they’ve prevented from reaching
the public is SCP - 3060, a series of CPAP
Machines that cause nighttime visions of frightening
entities.
MTF Omega-7, aka "Pandora's Box", was an experimental
task force which incorporated the use of highly
combat-effective SCPs – including SCP – 076,
better known as Abel.
The test showed initial success but after
they ran out of missions, Abel’s bloodlust
proved to be too great for the team to control
and the experiment as well as the task force
were scrapped.
However, this led to the creation of…
MTF Alpha-9, aka "Last Hope."
This is a mobile task force designed to train
viable SCPs to provide services to the Foundation
out in the field.
This group has learned the lessons of its
predecessor and has employed the use of more
measured and reasonable anomalies.
Those include SCP – 073, or Cain, the much-more
even-tempered brother of Able.
MTF Beta-7, aka the "Maz Hatters", are the
elite clean-up crew for anomalous biohazards,
chemical spills, and radiological disasters.
So, if an area suddenly looks like it’s
going to become Chernobyl’s scarier sequel,
or an anomalous, fast-spreading disease is
wreaking havoc over a wide area, the Maz Hatters
are the guys to call.They worked closely on
the containment of SCP - 1280, a kind of parasitic
nematode worm that often inject false memories
into their victims.
MTF Gamma-5, aka "Red Herrings", are the Foundation’s
chief disinformation division.
They prevent the leaks of classified information
to the public, and on the rare occasions that
this information does somehow get out, they’re
in charge of burying it and administering
necessary amnestic treatment to those affected.
It’s a thankless job, but you won’t remember
they did it, either way.
They gave amnestic treatment to the traumatized
victims of SCP - 1618, a malevolent urinal
which replaces the user’s valuables with
disgusting alternatives, from toilet paper
to pig intestines.
MTF Gamma-6, aka "Deep Feeders", investigate
and track deep sea or oceanic anomalies – a
job that commands the ultimate respect from
people with thalassophobia, that’s the fear
of the deep ocean.
If something terrifying and mysterious is
stirring down there in the abyss, you better
believe Gamma-6 are gonna be the first ones
down.
They keep a close eye on a number of anomalies,
such as SCP - 1264, an underwater amalgamation
of sunken ships, eager to drag down more vessels
and add them to its mass.
MTF Gamma-13, aka "Asimov's Lawbringers",
are a specialized task force devoted to investigating,
tracking, and apprehending anomalies originating
from Anderson Robotics, a group of interest
that produces anomalous robots and machines.
This includes examples of SCP - 2806, a number
of advanced, anomalous prosthetic body parts
that wish to attach themselves to a lacking
host - whether they want it or not.
MTF Delta-5, aka "Front Runners", are a large
group of autonomous deep-cover agents buried
in various Groups of Interest across the globe.
It’s their job to gather intelligence from
within to aid in the apprehension of anomalies
before these groups can get their hands on
them.
They also sometimes make use of anomalies
to track down others, such as when they requested
to use SCP - 185, a Russian R-105M radio used
during the Cold War that can receive signals
from any time period including encrypted ones,
but can also emit sound waves so powerful
they can literally kill you.
MTF Epsilon-9, aka "Fire Eaters", are the
Foundation’s resident pyromaniacs.
They’re the ones sent into missions involving
extremely high-temperature environments, and
they’re also highly skilled in the use of
powerful incendiary weapons.
If the Foundation needs to burn or avoid getting
burned, the Fire Eaters are the ones for the
job.
Their vital skills assisted in containing
SCP - 165, massive colonies of carnivorous,
parasitic mites that eat prey to the bone.
MTF Epsilon-11, "Nine-Tailed Fox", are another
one of the most classified Mobile Task Forces,
existing only under the oversight of Red Right
Hand.
They work internally, and are only dispatched
to Foundation sites when standard protocols
fail and multiple breaches are imminent.
They were brought in to deal with the SCP
- 2139 incident, a strange psychological phenomenon
that inexplicably increased the suggestibility
of Foundation staff at Site - 35.
This made the infected staff agree with everything
they heard.
MTF Zeta-9, "Mole Rats", are a task force
that specializes in the exploration and containment
of anomalous areas that are either enclosed
or underground – particularly if, due to
the effects of the anomaly, the spacetime
fabric of the area is unstable.
You may remember them from our series on SCP
– 1730: The mission into and out of the
anomalous Site 13.
MTF Eta-10, aka "See No Evil", are a team
that specializes in taking on dangerous memes
and cognitohazards that affect the victims
through visual contact.
One example is SCP - 1561, a crown that, when
worn, causes all those who see the person
wearing the crown to imagine the wearer as
their king - and immediately adopt positions
of servitude.
While MTF Eta-11, aka "Savage Beasts", serve
the opposite purpose.
They deal with musical or auditory anomalies,
and any cognitohazards that work through the
medium of sound, like SCP - 2402, a chord
progression which can regenerate old or dying
cells.
MTF Theta-4, aka "Gardeners", are a crack
team of agents who face off against any botanical
or plant-like anomalies.
Their skills were put to use against SCP - 1147,
a collection of plum tree seeds which can
grow out of literally any substance - even
ones that are totally inorganic.
MTF Theta-90, aka "Angle Grinders", are a
team that specialize in the two most frightening
things out there: Anomalies, and math.
These brainiacs deal with anomalous mathematical
issues like warped topologies and geometries.
Even listing an example of the kind of anomalies
they deal with here will make your head hurt,
so just be thankful they’re out there.
MTF Iota-10, "Damn Feds", are a huge network
of undercover agents based in federal and
local law enforcement agencies across the
globe.
They intercept any anomalous objects, beings,
or information, and make sure that it makes
its way out of police evidence lockers and
into Foundation hands without incident.
MTF Kappa-10, "Skynet", is a temporary team
of combined meatspace and virtual agents tracking
down and disrupting anomalous cyber-threats,
such as SCP - 2987, an external hard drive
basically capable of turning artificial intelligences
into living souls for trades with soul-consuming
anomalies.
MTF Lambda-5, aka "White Rabbits", are a group
that specializes in combating reality warpers
of all types, whether they’re messing with
spacetime or exhibiting godlike powers.
Some anomalies even respond directly to them,
like SCP - 2446 - a phenomenon where corpses,
often identical to living White Rabbits team
members, suddenly manifest around San Jose,
California.
MTF Lambda-12, "Pest Control", are a group
of agents who exclusively go after anomalous
vermin.
Incidentally, they’re one of the only MTFs
who’ve never lost members in the line of
duty.
Their purview includes SCP - 2810, an anomalous
pathogen that causes the victim’s cells
to become tiny versions of their own species
- like a human’s cells becoming cell-sized
humans.
MTF Lambda-14, "One Star Reviewers", are a
Task Force that deals with retail-oriented
anomalies.
Their main focus has become combating a sinister
group of interest known as The Ambrose Restaurant
- a chain of extradimensional restaurants
with strange and anomalous food and service.
MTF Mu-3, aka "Highest Bidders", is a mobile
task force devoted to preventing the Group
of Interest “Marshall, Carter, and Dark
Ltd.” from disseminating dangerous, anomalous
objects, and then obtaining and containing
these objects.
One such object is SCP - 2818, a number of
50 Cal sniper rifles that, when fired, turns
the shooter into a bullet and fires them.
MTF Mu-4, aka "Debuggers", are particularly
useful in the modern age, as they track and
contain anomalous electronics and technology
– including isolating and containing anomalous
websites and software.
One of the anomalies dealt with by the Debuggers
is SCP - 896, an online role playing game
that improves the physical and mental attributes
of the player when they name their character
after themselves.
Remember when we said you didn’t need to
call the Ghostbusters?
Well that wasn’t entirely true.
Sometimes you need to get MTF Mu-13, aka "Ghostbusters"
on the line since they are an MTF whose specialty
is tracking intangible or incorporeal anomalies,
particularly those considered sapient or sentient,
and they’re on call 24 hours a day to serve
all your supernatural containment needs, like
when you’re plagued by SCP - 1036, which
a number of haunted Kongolese fetish dolls.
MTF Nu-7, aka "Hammer Down", are the ones
you call when you need real heavy-duty work.
They’re a huge force with a massive stock
of army vehicles and heavy weaponry and are
only called in for truly catastrophic events.
They also assisted in the containment of SCP
- 939, the voice-imitating, amnestic-producing
red monsters.
MTF Epsilon-6, aka "Village Idiots", are a
group of agents whose specialty is investigating
and containing anomalous phenomena that occur
in rural or suburban areas.
If you live in a small town and you’re on
the run from a vicious monster, you better
hope the Village Idiots are on their way.
They contained SCP - 2561, a cat with a vintage
television set for a head, capable of causing
painful tinnitus.
MTF Pi-1, aka "City Slickers", are pretty
much the exact opposite of the village idiots.
They pursue anomalies in densely populated
urban areas, particularly in the New York
metropolitan area.
They assisted in the ongoing containment of
SCP - 1155, the incredibly bloodthirsty Predatory
Street Art.
MTF Sigma-66, aka "Sixteen Tons", are basically
the Foundation’s own version of the Suicide
Squad.
They’re a team made from captured members
of other groups of interest who aren’t particularly
loyal to the Foundation, but whose very particular
set of skills make up for that fact.
MTF Tau-5, aka "Samsara", are another group
you may remember from the events of SCP – 1730.
These are a group unlike any other – immortal
cyborgs made from the flesh of a dead god,
who can be upgraded as needed.
They’re equipped with experimental and state
of the art Foundation technology to take on
thaumaturgic, magical, and psionic threats.
MTF Psi-7, aka "Home Improvement", is a team
specializing in structural anomalies.
In plain speak, they deal with anomalous activities
concerning buildings, containing and sometimes
even demolishing when necessary with a variety
of heavy artillery.
For example, they counteract the nightmarish
SCP - 3050 - a building in North Carolina
that, once a year, fuses all living matter
inside into its own structure on an atomic
level.
MTF Psi-8, aka "The Silencers", are a team
devoted to containing reanimation anomalies
and those who’ve been affected by them.
If you’ve just come back from the dead,
then The Silencers are going to want to know
your location.
MTF Omega-0, aka "Ará Orún", are another
highly classified mobile task force that is
actually the memories of deceased Foundation
personnel preserved on the Foundation Intranet
system.
Their job is to protect their surviving co-workers
against informational threats on the servers.
They also contain SCP - 3664, a damaged but
highly advanced assault rifle existing in
the non-physical, conceptual space - It can
only be interacted with by thinking about
interacting with it.
And last but not least, MTF Omega-12, aka
"Achilles' Heels", is also an anomalous task
force.
These powerful reality warpers from another
dimension hunt down dangerous and powerful
reality warpers in ours.
You can thank these guys for every single
day that our reality continues on as normal
– or whatever “normal” means now.
They’re enemies of SCP - 3155, members of
the iconic Pinkerton Detective Agency with
anomalous abilities relating to combat.
Alright, we did it!
Of course, even this is only a sample of the
vast number of Mobile Task Forces at the Foundation’s
disposal who put their lives at risk every
day to keep humanity, normality, and reality
intact.
They seem to have a task force perfectly tailored
to every threat we could possibly encounter,
and as new threats are catalogued, more Mobile
Task Forces are sure to arise to meet them.
Want more in-depth explorations of any of
these groups and their epic missions?
Let us know in the comments down below!
Now go check out “SCP – 1730 – Epic
Battle at Site-13” and “SCP – 2662–
Cthulhu” for more of the Mobile Task Forces
you love right now!